lors du panel a sonné et on renoue avec
nos habitudes du vendredi avec nos chefs
de bureau parlementaire à ottawa et
québec matane blé morin et sébastien
bovet bonjour chers collègues bonsoir
plus tôt je trouve que c'est une très
belle tradition oui n'est ce pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des traditions
si belle pour les maintien et c'est ce
qu'on fait et beaucoup de choses au menu
aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'on va revenir
sur cette victoire du parti libéral ce
gouvernement minoritaire de justin
trudeau au mais auparavant il ya quand
même des dossiers chauds qu'on se doit
d'aborder avec vous chers collègues
commençons avec bah ça c'est très très
chaud thé tout frêle il ya un
développement intéressant j'ai deux
rappelle d'ailleurs pour ceux qui se
joignent à nous à l'instant même même
gwangju son extradition est
officiellement mises de côté ce sera le
retour pour elle vers la chine ce
dossier qui nous a tenus en haleine
madeleine depuis quoi 3 1 avec en
parallèle je dois parallèlement fait
c'est dit et les deux michael qui
croupissent dans des prisons chinoises
parlons de ce développement de céder des
conséquences politiques aussi de ce
développement est ce que le canada doit
faire mais c'est un développement majeur
parce que on avait l'impression que le
sort des deux michael ne pouvait pas
être réglée tant et aussi longtemps que
le cas même - joe est est pas réglé donc
là on a une pièce du casse-tête qui est
classé et c'est pas une petite pièce
mais est ce que ça va faire un effet
domino assez rapidement son ou
l'ignorent mais c'est quand même très
encourageant pour les deux mike hall
pour la famille de michael pour le
gouvernement canadien qui en faisait une
priorité mais pour ce qui est des
relations canada chine je pense quand
même qu'elles ont été sérieusement
endommagés et la population leurs
remarques et aussi je voyais un sondage
récent le printemps qui disait que moins
de 15 % de la population qui voient
favorablement la chine alors qu'il ya
cinq ans à peine c'était trois fois plus
de canadiens qui ont une vision oui
positive de la chaire est donc temps le
gouvernement canadien va aborder ses
relations avec la chine cl et michael
sont libérés ce qui n'est pas fait
encore
je pense que le gouvernement ne pourra
plus être naïf par rapport à la chine
qu'il doit devoir avoir les yeux grands
ouverts connaissant finalement les
tactiques de la chute du régime chinois
et ses bassins il ya sur tout pas été
tant question de la ferme - joe au cours
de la campagne et électorale mais bien
entendu que pour justin trudeau en tout
cas on verra comme dit madeleine ans
époque quand les développements se font
sourire en ce qui concerne les deux
mains comme ça va permettre de repartir
à neuf certains pans de son discours et
de son action politique c'est quand même
particulier s'ils arrivent quatre jours
après la conclusion des élections est ce
que c'était prévu avec le gars des vues
peut-être mais peut-être qu'on n'a pas
voulu interférer dans la campagne
électorale et ce serait d'une certaine
façon normale aussi
d'un point de vue policier on a toujours
dit que cette affaire là elle passer
s'ils devaient se résoudre à passer par
les états unis on le dit depuis le début
le canada était entre l'arbre et
l'écorcé entre la chine et les états
unis dans cette affaire et c'est à cause
des états unis que ça s'est dénoué 1
entente plaidoyer de culpabilité contre
la libération et l'abandon des autres
réseaux aux accusations qu'on lui
permette de partir donc monsieur trudeau
à partir de là c'est probablement
cailloux qui sort de son soulier mais
l'attend maintenant l'espoir c'est que
les deux maillots soit libéré puis je
pense que s'ils ne le font pas il y aura
une vive déception mais on va se dire à
quoi ça a servi finalement oui et puis
lorsqu'on parlait des relations canada
chine il ya aussi les relations canada
etats unis parce que le développement
aujourd'hui je dirais que ça vient
redonner une couche de peinture fraîche
sur les relations canado-américaines
parce que rappelez-vous 6 mai - jo ont
été arrêtés c'était à la demande des
états unis dedans oui donc le canada
était pris dans ce casse tête dans ce
noeud diplomatique en raison des états
unis donc le fait qu'il y ait un premier
dénouement dans cette affaire là ça
vient quand même aidé la relations
canado américaines parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y avait des liens se le com -
joe revenait finalement dans les
discussions donc la 6e cause ce dossier
là est réglé on pourra passer à autre
chose alors sur deux fronts la pression
qui baisse
mais il remet en question par exemple
est ce que quand il y aura un froid
diplomatique entre le canada et la chine
des canadiens seront menacés d'être
arrêté en chine est ce que est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de créer une espèce
de précédents dit pas qu'il y ait une
solution facile mais est ce qu on ne
s'expose pas en négociant avec moi oui
mais gwangju sa libération asker on
puisse être sous une certaine forme de
chantage éventuellement pour d'autres
affaires je pose la question pas de
réponse mais peut-être était-ce pose
cette question est là dessus les
communiqués qui venaient des états unis
aujourd'hui rappelait merci au canada
d'avoir respecté la règle de droit
s'était inscrit en toutes lettres comme
si on voulait donner l'impression que le
canada ne pas céder au chantage que le
canada a été vraiment ferme jusqu'à la
fin probablement sébastien pour éviter
de montrer qu'il y aurait une
possibilité de précédent il ya eu aussi
une offensive canadienne en acier des
alliés et des partenaires internationaux
pour justement dénoncé des cas de deux
prises d'otages pour des raisons
politiques et le canada avaient évité de
montrer du doigt la chine là dedans mais
j'ai bien l'impression que tout le monde
pensait à la chine donc c'était une
façon de montrer que il ya des alliés le
canada n'est pas seul là-dedans donc
s'il ya d'autres pays qui décident
d'agir de la sorte il va y avoir une
dénonciation
internationale mais ça c'est bon c'est
les grands principes parce qu'en théorie
s'applique ça c'est une autre qui est
derrière les grands principes et la
théorie il ya tout un travail en
coulisses évidemment dans tous les
circuits diplomatique de toute évidence
le canada jusqu'à présent en tout cas
ces actions commencent peut-être à
porter fruit on verra bien voilà pour ce
dossier c'est très important de
commencer avec ça on poursuit maintenant
un peu plus près de chez nous avec main
cette annonce on l'a vu aujourd'hui à
québec cette escouade qui était mise sur
pied pour lutter contre l' les armes à
feu la violence armée les deux paliers
de gouvernement sont aussi interpellés
en tout cas on y reviendra à madeleine
mais d'avoir sébastien parlons de cette
annonce est impressionnant voire même
guilbeault est derrière il y avait
combien de monde combien de
représentants des
quinzaines vingtaine pour annoncer le
projet le programme centaure donc c'est
un programme de lutte contre les armes à
feu qu'ils sont devenus une plaie dans
les grandes villes canadiennes notamment
montréal on a l'impression qu'il ya des
coups de feu sont tirés presque tous les
soirs dans certains quartiers chauds et
donc le problème si la circulation de
ces armes et aussi l'utilisation que
certains en font notamment les gangs de
rue alors
on met sur pied cette escouade qui est
une espèce de peut-être de calques de
carcajou vous rappelez de carcajou
l'installation sur québec avec d'autres
corps policiers qui mettaient en commun
leurs informations et leurs ressources
pour lutter contre un phénomène ponctuel
à ce moment là c'était les motards
criminels et donc on essaie d'endiguer
le phénomène qui devient de plus en plus
inquiétant le problème ici c'est la
frontière c'est à dire que on a beau
prendre des armes de poing illégal ou à
arrêter des gens qui les transporte le
problème c'est l'afflux de six armes de
poing illégale par notamment des
réserves autochtones j'en veux pas
pointer personne du doigt mais c'est
semble-t-il de cette réalité que ça
traverse relativement facilement la
frontière d'où l'idée de travailler avec
les autorités américaines ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle donc dans l'annoncé qui a
été faite aujourd'hui là où il ya
peut-être un point faible c'est sur le
communautaire oui il ya une
ombre communautaire la d'aider les
organismes communautaires à faire de la
prévention mais il va falloir faire plus
par extension vient peut-être dans les
prochaines semaines une aide aux
organismes communautaires pour essayer
de désamorcer à la racine le potentiel
dangereux de cette situation donc oui la
répression mais ça prendra aussi
beaucoup d'interventions sur le thème
évidemment québec agit maintenant dans
la mesure de ses moyens denis coderre
valérie plantes à chacun à l'occasion le
rappelle il y aussi le rôle que doit ou
que devrait jouer à ottawa madeleine
parlons-en avez vous remarqué qu'il y
avait pas de représentants d'ottawa
avait une entente quand même qu'un qui
concernait aussi la grc mais quand on
parle du département de la sécurité
intérieure des états unis deux corps
policiers autochtone de la police
ontarienne
ça ça aurait pu on aurait pu penser que
ottawa aurait pu être présent et puis
quand on parle de champ de compétence le
la frontière c'est quand même un champ
de compétence fédérale
j'ai pas entendu
personne à ottawa lever le petit doigt
pour se plaindre du point de presse de
madame guilbaud aujourd'hui et ça me
donne vraiment l'impression qu'ottawa
n'est pas dérangé du tout par cette
initiative là parce que c'est très très
très délicat pour le gouvernement
fédéral d'agir d'un océan à l'autre
parce qu'il ya des divisions nationales
sur la question des armes à feu il ya
des provinces ou dans certains endroits
du pays on est beaucoup moins enclins à
accroître les mesures de contrôle des
armes à feu donc ça devient un sujet qui
est extrêmement délicat pour le
gouvernement fédéral et dans le
programme libéral on avait vraiment
l'impression qu'on voulait se délester
de cette responsabilité-là dire par
exemple si vous voulez chères provinces
ou cher municipalité agir pour lutter
contre les armes de poing allez-y on va
vous donner de l'argent donc ça donnait
vraiment l'impression que on est bien
content si les provinces et les villes
s'en mêle et que le gouvernement fédéral
décide lui d'agir pour ce qui est des
des armes d'assaut de type militaire
mais pour ce qui est des armes de poing
on laisse les leviers d les provinces en
charge et donc ottawa ou six
représentants absent de cette conférence
de presse mais remarquez qu est le
premier ministre lui-même le premier
ministre et lui justin trudeau on le
voit pas beaucoup par les temps qui
court pourtant il a remporté cette
élection fédérale y ait quelques jours à
peine ça nous mène à notre dernier volet
de nos discussions d'aujourd'hui parce
que le temps file on va faire un petit
retour quand même sur cette victoire du
parti libéral commençons par un tableau
des chiffres parce que le portrait
n'était pas complet et définitif au
cours des derniers jours ça se précise
de plus en plus parce qu'il a connu
votre postale bien entendu il restait
des lutte très serrée pour lesquels on
n'avait pas tout ficelé voyez ce que ça
donne à ce stade si je le rappelle avec
encore 2 2 circonscriptions où les
choses ne sont pas réglées 159 pour le
parti libéral je parle de sièges 119
pour le parti conservateur 33 pour le
blog 24 25 24 et mes seins en tête pour
le npd et 2 pour le parti vert donc le
portrait se précise chers collègues
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ces deux sets ce portrait
électorale et en termes de députation
mais on l'a déjà dit mais c'est
tellement presque pareil que le portrait
de 2019 c'est à s'y méprendre tellement
que ça se ressemble il ya à peu près pas
d'écart entre les la députation de 2019
par rapport à 2021 quoi qu une
cinquantaine de nouveaux élus ans je
regardais ça tout à l'heure le dernier
et lula selon lui c'était le 50e
nouveaux députés qui allait faire son
entrée à la chambre des communes parce
que certaines personnes ne se sont pas
présents représentés ou parce qu'il ya
eu des pertes et des gays donc 50
nouveaux élus c'est quand même ça va
faire du sang neuf à la chambre des
communes mais la représente le partage
de la chambre des communes est quasiment
tel quel donc plus justin trudeau c'est
vraiment une victoire en 2007 le tableau
maintenant avec les résultats au québec
selon les dernières les derniers
chiffres on va regarder ça de près et on
va voir ici le bloc où il se situe après
cet appel au vote conservateur on se
demandait ce que ça allait donner 34
pour les libéraux 33 pour le québec 10
pour le parti conservateur sébastien
mais voilà que les libéraux surpasser
nos pistes soient hissées à une
circonscription près je pense que les
libéraux on avait 35 e la dernière fois
puis le bloc en avait trente deux donc
c'est le statu quo c'est du sur place
c'est comme si cette élection finalement
avaient rien donné
je m'excuse de dire ça donnait quelque
chose oui parce que il s'est passé des
choses pendant la campagne et l on en a
su un peu plus pour le programme mais en
maîtresse qu'elle était vraiment
nécessaire puisque avec le résultat
qu'on a là on se demande si elle était
nécessaire c'est un peu l'âme la
campagne électorale des perdants c'est à
dire que justin trudeau a pas gagné son
pari et renault tall a pas plus gagné
non plus sa campagne italie l'été au
même point où il était à la dissolution
de la chambre même chose pour le bloc
québécois même chose pour le npd les
verts c'est la débandade
même s'ils ont eu deux députés alors
qu'ils en avaient trois avants aux
élections de 2010 9 leur vote s'est
effondré alors c'est comme si tout le
monde a été perdant dans cette campagne
électorale on espère qu'ils ont compris
le message puis qui vont collaborer
ensemble pour faire avancer le pays
notamment lutter contre la pandémie qui
est une des choses les plus urgentes à
faire mais c'est comme si cette élection
avait pas de négoce on espère mais en
même temps c'est pas certain du tout que
c'est un climat avec les gens qui
arrivent qu'en chantant kumba yala j'ai
vraiment pas cette impression là entre
autres parce que renault tools voit son
leadership entre en ce moment menacé il
ya des gens qui se plaignent du fait
qu'il est recentré son parti donc et un
o'toole va devoir se présenter à la
chambre des communes en étant très très
combatif je pense pour rassurer ses
troupes et le parti libéral arrive en
disant moi j'ai un nouveau mandat donc
laissez moi gouverner en quelque sorte
mais bon je dis ça j'ai pas entendu
justin trudeau il ne nous a pas parlé
depuis le depuis
sa victoire de lundi
mais c'est ce qu'on entend un peu dans
son entourage qui disent bon nous un nom
on a maintenant un nouveau mandat qu'on
n'avait pas
pendant la pandémie donc vous voyez vous
c'est une dynamique où c'est pas trop
clair là comment on va s'organiser s'il
va y avoir de la bonne collaboration ou
pop mais ils vont bien devoir s'entendre
ultime mans parce que la population
n'accepterai pas qu'on veut tourner
votre première étape faut connaître la
composition aussi de ce cabinet
ministériel monsieur trudeau dr
madeleine est ce qu'on encaisse qui
circulent comme un humain hathaway ce
chapitre quand est-ce qu'on entendrait
on verra justin trudeau et qu'en est il
pour la suite bien on attend justin
trudeau moi j'attends
j'attends toujours de savoir quand il va
venir alors je peux pas si je peux pas
vous donner deux heures précises précise
précis à ce sujet là mais quand on veut
lui parler il va devoir avoir toutes les
réponses là par exemple à quand les
athlètes revient à quand la reprise des
travaux donc c'est probablement ce qu'il
est en train de préparer en ce moment
très bien alors d'ici là je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de semaine
reposez vous bien ça a été toute une
semaine pour vous particulièrement et
une prochaine on revienne